definitely cathartic for me and I think
as I look back it was more like you know
when I was when I'm acting some of these
parts that are dark and it stems from
all that I have and it comes out
and I'm like where did that come out
come from and then I if I really listen
to myself and and I could I know exactly
where it comes from I mean you must have
had moments playing with John Glover
right that must have been you know it
must have been funny or superficial or
whatever but then there are those
moments when I'm sure you guys looked at
each other and something you
know Primal happened yeah and what what
was crazy with John I know you love yeah
as an actor he uh he sometimes when I
had to go really emotional and just lose
my I get lost and I and after it he
would go
felt good didn't it oh yeah and I just
looked at him and I was like
yeah and it was just a moment just like
he's like almost it was paternal yeah
yeah and I needed that yeah it was weird
it was like I was going through these
emotions but he was also there yeah
knowing I know I know you're hurting a
little bit and you know good you're good
touch my heart yeah